taoufik jebali maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine qui nous rejoint
ce matin en direct pour la matinale
d'air france taoufik jebali
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
peut-être votre première réaction à vous
également sur les événements qui se sont
vécues hier soir au capitole
oui ce sont des événements tout à fait
surprenant pour les états unis
on a eu des cas pareils ailleurs dans le
monde mais les états unis à ma
connaissance et à travers l'histoire des
états unis
la passation de pouvoir a eu lieu
toujours dans le calme et dans le
respect de la constitution et des règles
cette fois ci c'est une confusion
extrêmement grave
par rapport aux états unis comme je
viens de dire c'est inhabituel mais
évidemment je crois que l'amérique va
surmonter cette épreuve et dans quelques
mois on va garder ces événements dans
les manuels scolaires les livres
d'histoire et les journaux mais je crois
qu'il faudra peut-être attendre des
évolutions politiques sociétales dans
les mois à venir mais certainement
qu'ils ne touchent pas nécessairement la
démocratie américaine qui va reprendre
sa marche